when you hear a record like last house
and like kind of like when we think back
to like maybe how important that record
was and how it kind of just helped
um it really kind of i think it helped
everyone out and it's such a cultural
like
i think a one train right
that's another one of those yeah
definitely i think glass house is like
one of those as well it just kind of
encapsulated
that time period and south by southwest
south by south west
free mixtapes [ __ ] it man do every show
you can
standing on you know not even on a stage
just freestyling and [ __ ] in the street
yeah how often do you go back and then
listen to that record and like what
memories does that record give you bring
a lot of memories people people want you
know me to perform that song i don't
you're the best you had the best verse
on that right i mean i mean thank you
you know i appreciate that but um for me
it was just like i think whiz and
currency know that respectfully they
know you i mean look yeah let's be
honest i will say the way that record
came about and then what happened with
my career after was because the homies
was definitely not only crushing it but
christian orange juice was
i mean i think it was about to come out
and just the excitement behind everybody
and kind of being new artists and we
were getting our own separate deals and
uh doing that record put me put my name
in front of a lot of people that wasn't
aware of what i was doing
because was glass house before crit was
here yeah i think glass house we did
that 2010 march i think cruiser came out
in april or may yeah i was about to say
it felt like it was like a like right
before yeah and so that that put me in a
lot of people cars and
who is this [ __ ] and then
between the beat because even the kind
of track i don't the homies that
wouldn't necessarily always rap on that
kind of kind of thing too
um and so after that going on tour being
able to perform that with wiz and
currency just kind of kept putting my
name out there up until we did the 2011
double xl cover that's when people
really saw who i was because i wouldn't
even put my face on covers and [ __ ] my
father didn't know what the [ __ ] i look
like that's real you were kind of you
were low-key early on yeah you know and
so your face wasn't on any of the
artwork nah very very just the brand
crit name and uh i remember going out on
the road with whis and then black and
yellow had took off while he was on the
road and just i was living in vegas that
[ __ ] was so crazy bro yeah in the energy
and i know it was it was thousands of
people had no idea who the [ __ ] i was
but it definitely gave me opportunity a
platform to get new fans